[Musique]
un roi au château de Versailles Charles
I est arrivé à 20h avec la reine Camilla
accompagné du couple présidentiel
Emmanuel et Brigitte Macron une grande
première pour un souverain britannique
depuis plus de 50 ans c'est la première
fois en tant que préfet que je suis
aussi ému parce que c'est un moment
extraordinaire le chef de l'État dit que
la dernière fois que souverain
britannique était reçu de cette manière
à versaill c'était la reine en 19 7 donc
évidemment c'est un très grand moment
avant son arrivée 150 prestigieux
invités ont traversé la cour royale du
château pour se rendre sur le tapis
rouge parmi les convives des
footballeurs comme Patrick Viera ou did
Drogba les comédiens Charlotte gansbour
et h grant le leader des Rolling Stone
Mick Jager plusieurs PDG étaient
également présents comme le milliardaire
du groupe LVMH Bernard Arnaud une soirée
de dîner d'État est une soirée
importante parce que c'est la
célébration d'une amitié entre deux deux
peuples de chefs d'État mais à travers
ses chefs d'État c'est de nations
évidemment qui se rencontent ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on voit pas
souvent je crois que j'en ai vu deux
déjà dans ma vie c'est peut-être le
dernier auquel j'assisterai devant le
château des centaines de journalistes
venus des quatre coins du monde ont
suivi cet événement
historique ces types d'événements
symbolisent l'unité entre deux pays qui
partagent la culture et l'histoire on
adore ça nous les journalistes ce côté
un peu glamour ce côté papier glacé et
surtout ce côté exceptionnel parce que
si on sait que le roi Charles II est
déjà venu à 34 reprises sur le
territoire français c'est la toute
première fois qu'il vient en France
depuis qu'il est roi les invités ont
ensuite dîné dans la galerie des glaces
sur une table de 60 m de long avec au
menu du hautar bleu de la volaille de
Bresse et des macarons à la rose le
repas s'est terminé aux alentours de
23h30